bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo un focus cette semaine sur
la pologne la pologne régulièrement dans
la rue pour défendre la démocratie et
l'audiovisuel public et réaction à une
chasse aux sorcières dans le pays où
depuis janvier une nouvelle loi
concernant les médias et une vague de
licenciements de journalistes sans
précédent pour étouffer les critiques
est ce une nouvelle étape dans la prise
de contrôle par les conservateurs de
tous les leviers de pouvoir a raison et
et vainqueur des élections législatives
en octobre dernier
en tout cas ces mesures prises par les
conservateurs polonais rappelle celle
instaurée par le pouvoir hongrois pour
mener sa politique sans aucun obstacle
alors que les partis au pouvoir c'est
dan 1 au nationalisme ultraconservateur
l'europe semble impuissante at elle les
moyens de réagir
on en débat en seconde partie d'émission
should i stay or should i go
l'actualité c'est aussi cet accord qui
permet d'éloigner pour un moment la
perspective d'une sortie de la
grande-bretagne de l'union européenne 30
heures de négociations et un accord
dégagé à bruxelles le week end dernier
david cameron est reparti chez lui avec
le statut spécial et les garanties qu'il
réclamait
à londres le premier ministre
britannique a annoncé la tenue d'un
référendum le 23 juin sur le maintien de
la grande-bretagne dans l'union indice
il va tenter de convaincre ses
compatriotes de rester parmi les 28
avant de débattre avec mes invités la
députée européenne et ancien commissaire
il ya nadine yannick jadot député
européen écologiste est le correspondant
de libération à bruxelles jean quatremer
avant de débattre on va revenir sur les
termes de cet accord qui permet d'éviter
pour un moment un break site
la sortie de la grande-bretagne de
l'union européenne olivier blague
un discours eurosceptique pour rester
dans l'union
david cameron était à westminster pour
défendre l'accord trouvé à bruxelles
le message est clair pour lui l'europe
est en marche et rien de plus depuis
notre intégration l'europe a été sur la
voie d'une union politique
nous n'avons jamais mais ça nous ne
l'avons jamais voulu maintenant la
grande bretagne pourra choisir
légalement d'être en dehors de ce
processus nous prendrons de l'europe ce
qui nous arrange pour influencer sur les
décisions qui nous concernent
en ayant toujours un pouvoir de décision
dans le plus grand marché du monde
le premier ministre a eu ce qu'il
voulait un statut spécifique pour le
royaume uni au sein de l'union
européenne
david cameron se targue notamment
d'avoir obtenu de nouvelles restrictions
sur l'accès à certaines aides sociales
pour les ressortissants des pays de lieu
vivant au royaume uni autre succès pour
le premier ministre une plus grande
protection du centre financier de la
city au 10 downing street ce sont les
membres du gouvernement qu'il a fallu
convaincre un appel à la raison je pense
que nous serions plus en sécurité dans
une robe réformer pour continuer de
travailler avec nos partenaires
européens pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
être leader d'un des plus grands
ensembles du monde nous rendra plus
faire plus fort en ayant moins
d'obligation envers l'union européenne
autant d'arguments qui n'arrivent pas à
rallier tous les membres de son propre
camp
le maire conservateur de londres votera
pour la sortie de l'union j'aimerais
construire une nouvelle relation avec
leur robe rouge basée sur le commerce et
la coopération encore plus loin sur des
réglementations sur la dernière chose
que je veux c'est le mot poser à david
cameron et à son gouvernement
mais après y avoir bien réfléchi je ne
peux pas faire une confiance que je vous
dis là bien pour une sortie de l'union
européenne selon un sondage les
britanniques se disait en majorité pour
le maintien de leur pays dans l'union
européenne
le camp qui veut rester dans lieu à de
bonnes raisons d'être confiants
les indécis sont moins prompte aux
risques il voit le bric sites comme une
option incertaine je pense que les
arguments des politiques qui veulent
sortir de l'union européenne peuvent se
retourner contre les attaques
terroristes à paris la crise des
réfugiés ou les questions liées à
l'immigration en grande-bretagne qui
suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude tout fait
que l'option du maintien pour garder
l'avantagé du suspense le 23 juin jour
du référendum
voilà reportage d'olivier boulenc nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau viviane
reding bonjour vous êtes ce député
européenne du luxembourg membre du
groupe ppe 1 qui représente la droite
ici au parlement européen vous étiez ya
pas si longtemps commissaire européenne
chargée des droits de l'homme et vice
président de la commission européenne
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et yannick jadot bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député européen français écologiste
vous dise il ya pas longtemps je suis je
ne suis pas pour garder la
grande-bretagne à tout prix à que david
cameron prenne ses responsabilités enfin
jean quatremer qu'on ne présente plus
ici vous êtes un peu notre boussole
bonjour vous êtes surtout correspondant
dur la libération à bruxelles voilà
référendum le 23 juin david cameron a
quatre mois pour convaincre ses
compatriotes de rester dans l'union
européenne
il est sorti gagnant de cette épreuve de
force avec bruxelles viviane reding je
ne pense pas je pense que c'est l'europe
qui est sortie perdante et on a réussi
maintenant pendant des années à faire
sans la grande bretagne parce qu'elle ne
participe à aucune des politiques fortes
à part celle du marché alors on pourrait
très bien faire sans elle et j'attends
le moment véritablement où ils sortent
et ne laisse continuer sur la voie que
nous avons choisi ensemble sans la
grande bretagne qui est gagné jabra
l'europe les extrêmes droites les
cyniques les tacticiens ont gagné parce
qu'au fond tout ça c'est un pari
tactique pour cameron pour rester au
pouvoir et se fout royalement de
l'avenir de la grande-bretagne et de
l'europe
il est totalement cynique quand il dit
je déteste bruxelles et quand il dit
dans votre reportage
l'europe c'est simplement ce que j'en
veux et au fond c'est un tapis rouge
toutes les extrêmes droites pour tous
ceux qui refusent l'europe parce qu'au
fond qu'est ce que ça raconte cette
histoire qu'on peut aller à bruxelles
taper du poing sur la table obtenir des
concessions obtenir le détricotage d'une
europe qui ne fonctionne pas l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est de faire plus d'europe
sur l'europe fiscale sur l'europe de
l'investissement sur l'europe sociale
donc c'est de sortir du statu quo qui
est terrible et là on a détricoté mais
je suis extrêmement en colère vis-à-vis
du président l'an vis-à-vis des autres
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens qui laissent la faire se
détricoter
et quand j'entends un président de la
république au bout de son quinquennat
nous dira je prendrai des initiatives
après le référendum britannique
je trouve que c'est du renoncement
absolue en matière européenne c'est très
grave sur les détails de l'accord jean
quatremer au niveau des prestations
sociales il différencie citoyens
britanniques et les restes le reste des
européens
le détail de l'accord je vous dire
franchement on s'en fiche ouais
la question se pose absolument pas en
ces termes là c'est un problème
britannique au britannique je pense que
les chefs de gouvernement l'union
européenne la commission on n'aurait
jamais dû négocier qu'à la grande
bretagne
parce que là il s'agit pas d'un traité
qui a été rejetée par un parlement par
un peuple lors d'un référendum
ils ont un problème est un problème
interne vis-à-vis de l'europe qui n'ont
jamais réussi à régler
ils ont adhéré aux 73 ans 75 il faut un
premier référendum
est-ce que ça règle le problème
britannique en europe non et le
référendum est positif des délais de
l'accession au pouvoir de margaret
thatcher en 79 elle bloque c'est à vous
maintenant et les bacs et ensuite une
série de crises permanentes
quelles que soient les concessions qu'on
ait faite à la grande bretagne
on a eu droit un an un an après six mois
après deux ans après à de nouvelles
demandes de concessions donc là ça
suffit
le gouvernement s'il avait été un petit
peu courageux ont été tirés crabe la
cameron c'est ton problème ce n'est pas
le nôtre
effectivement là je rejoins yannick sur
la responsabilité de françois hollande
parce que bon la chancelière allemande
aurait pu le faire quelque chose mais
elle est empêtrée dans la crise des
réfugiés et où tout le monde la laisse
tomber elle est seule dans cette affaire
françois hollande aurait pu s'il avait
eu un minimum d'idées sur l'europe dire
écoutez on a appris avec les
britanniques qui se décident ils vont
sans doute partir de ce n'est pas notre
problème
nous allons approfondir l'union
européenne j'ai des idées pour cela
françois hollande
encore une fois n'a rien fait le seul
moment il a tapé du poing sur la table
pendant ce conseil et a tapé du poing
sur la table c'est pour demander une
interruption de séance de deux heures
pour aller parler à france inter
devant son opinion publique nationale
bravo quel courage un problème donc
britannique au britannique vous dites en
grande bretagne en tout cas l'inquiétude
un des milieux d'affaires après le
ralliement du bouillonnant boris johnson
aux partisans d'une sortie de l'europe
la livre sterling a dévissé à son niveau
le plus faible en sept ans un car les
marchés s'inquiètent du poids que
pourrait avoir le maire de londres sur
le référendum du bref dit johnson et
iconoclaste très populaire david cameron
lui a d'ailleurs répondu lors d'un
échange musclé on écoute et on réagit
juste après
puis je demandais à mon cher ami le
premier ministre d'expliquer au
parlement et au pays
en quoi cet accord nous rend la
souveraineté dans le domaine de la
fabrication de la loi ici dans cette
assemblée
cet accord nous redonne un certain
pouvoir sur les allocations il nous
donne un certain pouvoir sur
l'immigration il nous redonne un certain
pouvoir sur les sauvetages financiers
mais plus que ça à part ce qui nous sera
jamais du menu ont tous vécu les trois
il signifie qu'à l'avenir aucun tribunal
européen ne pourra plus prévaloir sur ce
pays
échanges musclés 1 au sein même du parti
qu'aux conservateurs on est on est
divisé c'est pas gagné pour le
référendum
ce n'est pas gagné mais johnson espère
gagner la présidence du gouvernement
c'est un cirque condamné en fait un
problème britannique
c'est un cirque complètement un
britannique qui se joue en ce moment et
nous en souffrons et voyez vous regardez
un peu l'europe est comme une grande
famille et il y a dans cette famille un
qui toujours veut faire autrement et qui
surtout au moment où la famille est
fragilisée où il faudrait serrer les
rangs fait de nouveau des siens alors je
pense que nous devrions collectivement
une fois dire que c'en est assez
et que nous serons beaucoup mieux sans
la grande bretagne là la grande bretagne
fait pas partie de la zone euro elle
fait pas partie de schengen elle a même
eu des dérogations sur le budget
européen vous rappeler le we want my
money back de margaret thatcher
est ce que ce serait vraiment terrible
que les britanniques sorte une bonne
fois pour toutes de l'europe
ça serait pas une bonne nouvelle vous
savez on a été pendant quelques années
ces dernières années entre deux options
soit ce serait dramatique qu'on perde
amende de la famille parce que ce serait
la dynamique d'intégration et de
construction collective vers le futur
qui seraient perdus l'autre option c'est
de dire au fond le statu quo de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui sanomat
je pas le statu quo nous fait reculer
fait gagner tous les nationalismes et
nous empêche de prouver l'absolue
nécessité de l'union européenne donc on
avait le choix entre ces deux options
garder tout le monde ou avancés avec
ceux qui veulent avancer et moi
aujourd'hui j'ai clairement choisi mon
camp
si la pologne ne veut plus avancer on en
parlera sur la solidarité tout ça on
doit trancher on doit parler de la
solidarité des budgets
si la grande bretagne de sortir mais
qu'elle assume ses responsabilités vous
entendez le discours au fond c'est de
dire nous voulons uniquement ce qui nous
intéresse dans l'union européenne et au
fond nous voulons uniquement défendre
les intérêts de la city ou b donc c'est
là au fond c'est celle est porteur de la
crise financière et celle est porteur
d'un dérèglement profond de nos
économies qui gagne dans cette affaire
c'est vraiment grave à ce qu'il va être
intéressant ça va être sur le les
conséquences sur la grande bretagne est
le même les sondages aujourd'hui montre
que l'ecosse le pays de galles irlande
du nord sont prêts à voter à peu près à
77% 80% pour rester dans l'union sont
les anglais qui veulent sortir de
l'union et encore pas londres
c'est vraiment la campagne anglaise qui
va voter pour ce faire l'union qu'est ce
qui va se passer si elle vraiment si ça
se confirme c'est à dire que c'est le
oui l emporte uniquement grâce à
l'angleterre
la grande bretagne va exploser vous
rendez compte c'est à dire que ils vont
effectivement nous poser un problème
interne mais à côté du problème
britannique qui reste imploser dans
cette affaire ça va être rien nous ça
nous permet alors je pense effectivement
il risque d'avoir un effet délétère sur
l'union européenne mais qui risquent
d'être effacées par la disparition pure
et simple de la grande bretagne et au
passage au risque de gagner le sans
doute les causes qui voudraient adhérer
rester dans l'union européenne voir
l'irlande du nord le pays de galles
c'est moins sûr mais ça va être
extraordinaire donc cameron dans cette
affaire c'est vraiment l'incendiaire
c'est le le pompiers incendiaires c'est
dramatique ce qu'il a fait s'il joue
avec l'europe
il joue avec son pays et tout ça comme
disait viviane reding tout à l'heure
uniquement pour des questions de
politique intérieure non pas la grande
bretagne
mais au parti conservateur c'est ça qui
est dingue je vous presse et si oui on
peut faire une comparaison c'est le
conte faisait tout à l'heure avant le
début de l'émission
c'est laurent fabius en 2005 face à
françois hollande laurent fabius à jouer
l'avenir du pays pour prendre le
contrôle du parti socialiste face à
françois hollande
merci laurent fabius
dit ça paye les présidents du conseil
constitutionnel et donc c'est exactement
ce qui est en train de se passer en
grande-bretagne
bon je vous propose de refermer cette
page sur le bras et le site et je vous
propose maintenant qu'on a et on semble
un peu plus à l'est de l'union
européenne en pologne
c'est une chasse aux sorcières en
pologne où depuis janvier une nouvelle
loi concernant les médias il ya eu une
vague de licenciements sans précédent de
journalistes à pour étouffer les
critiques face au tollé la première
ministre polonaise s'est défendu à le
mois dernier devant le parlement
européen pologne
les conservateurs au pouvoir mettre les
médias au pas c'est un reportage à
varsovie de gerland drilles
la pologne dans la rue pour défendre la
démocratie et l'audiovisuel public votée
la nuit du 31 décembre et promulguée
tout début janvier une nouvelle loi déjà
permis de remplacer les dirigeants de la
télé publique polonaise et plusieurs
journalistes ont été remerciés désormais
c'est le ministère des finances qui
nomme directement les dirigeants des
médias publics leur contrat est plus
précaire
ils peuvent être envoyés à tout moment
constat new hampshire sont conviés tous
ceux qui ne sont pas nationaliste
catholique ou traditionalistes n'auront
plus la possibilité d'exprimer leurs
opinions
cela ne plaît pas du tout mais j'admire
pandore j'espère que l'europe va
continuer de faire pression sur la
pologne qu'elle ne décevra pas les
polonais comme elle a déçu les hongrois
qui n'arrivent pas à s'arracher à la
quasi dictature dans laquelle ils sont
je compte sur l'europe pour ne pas nous
laisser tomber l'europe s'inquiète et
demandent des comptes
une procédure d' enquête sur la
sauvegarde de la démocratie est
enclenchée alors la liberté d'expression
est elle en train de disparaître en
pologne
bienvenue à la gazeta wyborcza le
premier quotidien d'opposition du pays
ce soir le débat sur la démocratie et la
liberté d'expression fait salle comble
les inviter les journalistes et les
patrons de presse
fraîchement débarqué c'est surtout les
programmes d'information qui ont
beaucoup changé dans ces rendez vous
clef de l'info ils ont immédiatement
changer les personnes tous les
directeurs des programmes qui étaient
opposés au nouveau régime
et d'autres comme moi qui ont préféré
démissionner à partir de mars
il y aura peut-être de nouveaux
programmes culturels sur le théâtre ou
le cinéma
les là il faut encore attendre face à
eux plusieurs générations et des
militants pro démocratie
ces journalistes restent très populaires
comme cet ancien présentateur du journal
télévisé
je viens vous remercier au nom de toute
ma famille moi vous savez j'ai vécu
beaucoup de choses
j'ai 73 ans je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus je suis ému mais je vous félicite
face aux risques de censure il existe
encore plusieurs garanties avec deux
chaînes d'informations privées et
surtout internet et les réseaux sociaux
du côté de la télé publique le regard
est bien sûr tout à fait différent
magdalena vient d'être nommé à un poste
de direction
mais elle refuse toute étiquette
politique en pologne
cette chasse aux sorcières n'a rien de
nouveau quand il y avait le p o qui est
arrivé au pouvoir
oui il ya huit ans ils ont tout faire
pour prendre la télévision la radio
publique
et ils ont nettoyé les gens qui
travaillaient qui étaient dix ans du
parti de l'opposition
je suis très inquiète parce qu'il se
passe dans l'union européenne
parce que l'union européenne a été très
mal informés ils ont pris le parti d'un
seul parti
oh
pas de dictature mais des inquiétudes et
une procédure de sauvegarde de l'état de
droit a lancé par l'europe
une procédure rare mise en place en 2014
pour la hongrie de viktor orban
mamadou bah oui il n'empêche ce taux à
ces niches
vous savez ici la situation est tout à
fait différente avec la hongrie et la
russie où l'opposition est très faibles
en pologne
l'opposition est bien structuré et
solide face au gouvernement
elle est soutenue par l'opinion publique
mais la presse que les mêmes forces que
le parti au pouvoir donc c'est tout à
fait différent mais en même temps c'est
une situation très conflictuelle le pis
le parti gouvernemental droit et justice
s'appuie sur le soutien de la population
lors des dernières élections et réclame
la souveraineté du pays
mais une nouvelle loi sur les médias
plus ample et plus radicale est déjà
prévue pour le printemps prochain
voilà un reportage de jérôme andrieu
ville de reading on vous connaît bien en
france en 2010 concernant les roms en
france et leurs expulsions à vous aviez
mis en garde la france
à l'époque vous étiez commissaire en
charge des droits de l'homme nous aviez
même osé un parallèle avec les
déportations de la seconde guerre
mondiale sur la pologne vous ferriez la
même mise en garde concernant ses droits
et libertés bafouées la liberté de la
presse
ce qui se passe en pologne est
extrêmement grave et c'est pour des cas
pareils que j'ai créée en mars 2014 ce
cadre état de droit après l'expérience
faite avec la hongrie après l'expérience
faite pour le démantèlement de la cour
supérieure aussi avec la roumanie
donc il fallait un instrument pour
pouvoir agir
je n'aurais jamais cru à l'époque en
2014 et que cet instrument serait mise
en pratique pour la pologne parce que la
pologne
rien ne va plus la seule chose qui va
encore et on l'a vu dans le reportage
c'est que en pologne à une société
civile qui se boit dans la rue il y à
une opposition ce qui n'existait pas en
hongrie donc en pologne où l'attendent
une reportage les partisans du pouvoir
ils disent que l'europe elle a été mal
informé à cette chasse aux sorcières
c'est normal ça fait depuis toujours on
a gagné les élections c'est la
démocratie
on peut changer les journalistes comme
on veut et que l'europe est ce qu'elle a
pris le parti de l'opposition avant la
pause
il faut avoir une chose c'est que les en
pologne le parti droit et justice n'a
obtenu que 37% des voix et 52 ou 51 %
des sièges
donc c'est passé la situation hongroise
est majoritaire il a formé après une
minute il est majoritaire mais il n'a
pas la majorité nécessaire pour modifier
la constitution ce qui est complètement
différent hongrie où ils ont tenu deux
tiers des voix deux tiers des sièges et
donc qu'ils ont ils viktor orban
on peut le critiquer mais il a la
légitimité 1800 soir mais voilà pourtant
le premier ministre hongrois
effectivement à la légitimité pour
transformer son pliant quelque chose qui
nous plaît pas mais c'est légitime
en pologne c'est pas du tout le cas cela
qu'ils sont en train de tordre l'état de
droit pour imposer en fait de facto une
réforme de la constitution qui portent
atteinte aux libertés publiques
alors face à ça c'est vrai que l'europe
et les traits 10 min pourquoi parce que
l'europe elle est
c'est d'abord un marché unique c'est
vrai qu'on a des règlements on a des
textes extrêmement précis sur la taille
des boîtes de petits pois sur la façon
dont est votre briquet le rétroviseur
d'un tracteur etc
les normes des ascenseurs mais on n'a
rien sur l'état de droit
parce que les traités ne le permettent
pas c'est à dire qu en clair lyon
d'états souverains au cinéma parce qu'en
fait pour rentrer dans l'union
européenne
il faut être parfait plus que parfait
puis une fois qu'on est dedans fait ce
qu'on veut nous c'est la pologne en
critique mais on pourrait faire
exactement la même chose en france
amnesty international vient de rendre un
rapport sur les dérives autoritaires en
france qui est inquiétant c'est à dire
qu'avec l'état d'urgence avec la
transcription dans la loi dans le droit
pénal des mesures de l'état d'urgence
les perquisitions les le fait qu'on
mette à l'écart le juge judiciaire etc
c'est la même chose je vous rappelle
quand même aussi que si nicolas sarkozy
avait décidé de nommer lui même les pdg
d'ace du service audiovisuel envie au
public en france donc eric jadot et à
des dérives tous d'asile jadot la
situation est comparable à la situation
polonais compare avec la fin non non
j'en passe là ils veulent faire des
médias au fond le rtf qu'on avait en
france d'aviron choisi non seulement les
directeurs ont choisi la ligne politique
des médias et ont choisi les
journalistes là où la journaliste à
raison comme dans son c'est vrai que
d'autres l'ont fait avant mais ça
justifie pas la journée le public de la
justice
le fasse à son tour ils ont dix en train
de transformer le tribunal
constitutionnel pour faire en sorte
qu'au fond le tribunal constitutionnel
ne puisse plus opposé à une quelconque
loi qui viendrait en infraction de la
constitution polonaise
donc là il ya eu effectivement une
dérive autoritaire une dérive
antidémocratique et ce qui est
inquiétant alors il ya des moyens et ça
a été le travail qui avait fait
notamment la commissaire reding qui est
mais vous souvenez quand jorg haider
était arrivé dans une coalition en
autriche
tout le monde était furieux tout le
monde avait combattu ce gouvernement de
coalition
la difficulté est là ça rejoint un peu
de ce que dit jean quatremer c'est
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gouvernements
se mettent à la faute sur l'état de
droit
les danois qui spoile les qui spolie
les sujets bien des réfugiés le regarder
ce qui se passe en finlande regarder ce
qui se passe un peu partout en europe et
qu'au fond on a une coalition de
gouvernement qui disent je vais pas
taper sur les polonais parce que je suis
pas capable de savoir ce que je vais
faire demain qui va être contraire aux
libertés publiques elle est adroit cse
l'émigré je voudrais juste interrompue
parce que quand même en france imaginons
qu'en france mais je combats je combats
les voilages urgence la présence de
gîtes judiciarisation on vient de nommer
le prince hollande y en eut décidé de
nommer son mini affaires étrangères
président du conseil constitutionnel et
le parlement n'a aucun moyen de s'y
opposer il faut que deux tiers des
députés votre compte lire en clair ça
n'arrivera jamais à la planète voilà
donc on nomme ses amis et ses copains
pour contrôler la voie constitutionnelle
vous parlez des médias mais moi je vous
dis regret ce qui se passe en france
c'est pas le public et dans le privé
qu'est ce que fait bolloré par exemple
sur canal+ c'est la même chose
alors effectivement c'est pas nous c'est
pas l'état donc on va revenir à son
général à à la pologne
on a l'impression que les peuples de
l'union européenne semblent tentés par
les régimes autoritaires comme le montre
la hongrie la pologne la slovaquie mais
c'est toujours le même système
il ya un gouvernement qui ne satisfait
pas on vote un gouvernement extrême et
ce gouvernement extrême prend des
mesures autoritaires et ça commence
toujours mais à chaque fois ça commence
par la justice le tribunal
constitutionnel
il est mis hors usage ça s'est passé en
roumanie sous les socialistes ça s'est
passé sous un gouvernement de droite en
hongrie ça se passe sous un gouvernement
de droite maintenant en pologne
et puis la même chose le ministre de la
justice devient en même temps procureur
vous imaginez ça la séparation des des
droits c'est pas possible
les juges doivent démontrer qu'ils n'ont
pas une vue pendant cinq ans une
affiliation à un autre parti que celui
au pouvoir c'est à dire ça
d
tout ce que nous avons comme règle
justice règles de déontologie règles de
droit commun on a aussi l'impression
qu'elle est certaine arrogance chez
beaucoup de pays d'europe centrale qui
d'un côté se permettent de critiquer les
règles de fonctionnement de l'europe
ces valeurs la liberté de la presse mais
de l'autre côté ils sont bien contents
de recevoir l'aide financière de
l'europe en europe l'europe c'est quoi
une machine à cash
les deux plus grands bénéficiaires de
ces fonds repère des fonds structurels
sont la pologne la hongrie avec
respectivement 86 milliards pour pour la
pologne et 25 milliards pour pour la
hongrie alors que c'est que ces
dirigeants sont eurosceptiques c'est
normal c'est 4% de leur pib à ce que les
choses sont en train de changer et ça
c'est aussi très inquiétant ou
s'inquiétant que le brésil matteo renzi
lors du conseil européen de la semaine
dernière a enfin dit son fait au
polonais et hongrois en disant écoutez
la solidarité c'est à double sens si
vous voulez pas accueillir les réfugiés
on va vous couper les fonds structurels
à berlin on dit la même chose et moi
j'ai parlé avec des dirigeants italiens
qui m'ont dit maintenant ils commencent
à nous fatiguer la chute du mur c'est 89
il continue à nous à boyer au visage
comme si on était responsable de ce qui
s'était passé avant 89 et nous allons
leur parler
sur le même ton et c'est vrai que ça
risque de se passer c'est à dire qu'on
va négocier le budget européen à partir
de 2018 2019 je crois et ça va être
sanglant parce que là ça va être le
donnant donnant avant de nous quitter je
voulais qu'on dise un mot sur la
fermeture des frontières entre la
pologne entre la belgique et la france
on est toujours sur le thème de la crise
des réfugiés donc fermeture des
frontières par peur de des migrants en
provenance de calais yannick jadot
c'est dramatique c'est on voit un
système qui s'affaisse je dire la remise
en cause de la liberté de circulation
c'est au fond mettre la tête dans le
sable sur tous nos sujets sur la
question des réfugiés
on laisse madame merkel tout gérer et
forcément ça devient un problème chez
elle
on lui a laissé tout gérer la grèce et
c'était un problème pour les grecs
aujourd'hui les grecs ont besoin de
solidarité les allemands
besoin de solidarité tout le monde au
fonds il ya un nouveau pull ce qui est
en train de se faire les polonais
veulent la solidarité mais ils veulent
pas de d'intégration politique
tous les autres vols la solidarité pour
gérer ensemble les problèmes donc il ya
une démarche à faire pour nos dirigeants
et de dire faisons de l'investissement
redonnant du sens au paquet européen que
ce soit sur les libertés publiques comme
sur les opportunités économiques et
sociales et si on redonne du sens là si
on redonne au fond un ballon d'oxygène
en matière d'investissement on peut re
discuter du rachat de reading c'est la
fin du principe de libre circulation des
personnes
je voudrais quand même revenir à votre
question qui a complètement étaient
oubliées et bien là le fait de calais
sur la fermeture des frontières entre la
france et la belgique sait et on revient
au début de notre discussion
c'est grâce à la politique de la
grande-bretagne
parce que là aussi on voit que il n'ya
pas de solidarité
or une famille sans solidarité ça ne
peut pas faire seul anglais mais les
anglais doivent prendre sur eux
la partie et ils ne font pas partie de
chagny ne font pas partie de la charte
sociale
ils ne font pas partie du de la charte
des droits fondamentaux ils font partie
de rien la faîtière boonana besoins en
bretagne voilà c'est pas avec les simbas
ce sera de viviane reding
yannick jadot jean quatremer merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation c'est
la fin d'europe d'où merci de nous avoir
suivis merci à toute l'équipe technique
du parlement européen ici à bruxelles
avec pascal simard à la réalisation on
n'en parle pas souvent ils sont derrière
la caméra mais ils font un vrai bon
travail merci à eux la semaine prochaine
vous retrouvez nos ramadi à cette même
place d'ici là restez avec nous sur les
chaînes parlementaires bail
m